Speaker 1: guys, this voicemail
is really depressing. Here's a
caller who called the voicemail number
yesterday, two one nine two, David P.
and he explains he's going to get vaccinated,
but he didn't want to. Why? Because his mom
got a headache from the vaccine. Listen to this.
Speaker 8: Hey, David, how's it going? So I work
at Ohio University in Ohio, and they just mandated
the coronavirus vaccine. OK, it looks like I'm
going to have to get it because I don't want
to be poor and stupid, so I'm going to get it.
Speaker 1: I guess what he means is it would
be he would lose his job and he needs money.
The stupid part, I don't know if he means it
would be stupid not to get vaccinated or would be
stupid to lose your job. But then listen to this.
Speaker 8: But I was holding off until now because
my mom got it and she got very sick from
it. She had a really bad headache and
I just didn't want to go through that.
So I was kind of putting it off because
what I didn't want to get it. My mom got very
sick, you know. So I'm just wondering what what
your opinions are about places that are mandating
the vaccine for people that don't want to get
it. It's what your opinions are about that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I am absolutely fine with
the covid vaccine being added to the list of
required vaccines, if that's what an employer
or an organization wants to do for kids
to go to school. There's been a long list
of necessary vaccines for a very long time.
Vaccine requirements aren't new. They're just
adding the now approved covid vaccine to the
list. But I'm really worried about a headache.
You know, I got a headache when I got the vaccine.
I had a mild fever. My arm hurt. It was like one
night where I didn't feel well. I felt flu like
and then I was better and then I was vaccinated.
You would choose not to get the vaccine to avoid
one day of headache when it reduces your risk
of getting hospitalized or dying from covered by
more than 90 percent. That doesn't make sense. And
that's really, really concerning to me. And I've
heard it from others, too. I don't know. I heard,
but I don't want my arm to hurt for a day, but.
Right. But then you'll be vaccinated and you'll be
significantly protected against hospitalization
and death. Is it don't you? Yeah,
but my arm I mean, I don't know. I might have a
headache. We've got a real uphill battle here,
guys. Real uphill battle. But it sounds like this
guy is going to get the vaccine, and that's good.
We've got a great bonus show for you today. Sign
up at David Pakman dot com and get instant access.